Hey, welcome back.
And in this video, we're gonna have a look
at ChatGPT projects.
You can think of ChatGPT projects a little bit like a folder.
You can put specific information in there,
files, custom instructions.
Whenever you have a project or something specific,
I'd recommend putting it inside of a ChatGPT project.
That way you can keep everything nice and tidy.
And when you're specifically wanting
to talk about that project,
you'll then navigate into that project
and go into it almost like a folder.
Let's see how we can create projects.
Go over to the left-hand side,
and then you can see you've got projects
above your chat history.
I want you to click on New Project,
and then I want you to give your project a name.
I'm gonna call mine Travel Holidays,
and then you're gonna click Create Project.
It will take a little bit of time to create a project,
so we'll just wait for that.
After you've got a project that's being created,
you can add files to this project.
Now, these files are specifically attached to this project,
so you can add custom instructions,
so what kind of things are specific to this project.
So I'll say, only give me advice about where to go,
not what to eat.
We can also drag in files,
and you can see that this uses the default memory.
So projects can access memories from outside chats
and vice versa.
So it will access your default memory.
You can add files and instructions.
And what's clever about this
is that these instructions and these files
are only specific to this project.
So that means I could have a specific way
of talking with chat GPT inside of a project.
Let's say I've asked, for example,
I want to go on holiday to Brazil,
can you give me some recommendations?
You'll see it's given us some information about this,
specific places to go.
That's great, but now if we look on the left-hand side,
can you see our Travel Holidays folder or project
has now got a recent chat history.
Now, if I click on this again,
you'll see that we've got our one conversation here,
so we can actually share this conversation.
We can re-engage with this conversation.
So it's a way for you to,
rather than have a load of your conversations
and you're endlessly scrolling,
trying to find that conversation that you had,
that's where you're starting to use projects, right?
So when you've got 100 or 300 different types
of chat GPT conversations,
you just can't seem to find them.
So that's a really, really good use case
for using these projects inside of chat GPT.
One other thing that I really like to do is,
let's say I create a new conversation outside of the project.
So I'm looking to learn about Spain and travel.
One way that I like to do this is you'll see
that over here in the sort of left-hand side,
the conversations come up about Spain,
but I really wanted to have had that inside of my project.
So you can just click on the triple dots
and then you can move that to a specific project,
so Travel Holidays.
And now that Spain information is there
with my Brazil information.
So it's kind of one of these things where like,
if you do forget to specifically talk inside of a project,
then you can always move that chat session
over into the project itself.
So I find these two ways of working
are really, really good for tidying up.
And then I don't have to manually search all the chats.
I can just keep the relevant chats
under a specific project.
The other benefit that you get though from this
is that as you talk more in a specific project,
chat GPT is clever enough to pull in relevant types
of chats within side that project itself.
So it starts to remember things specifically
from chat histories that have happened
inside of that project.
You can also add files.
I don't find myself doing that much,
but obviously if you're in data analysis
or you're pulling in relevant CSVs or PDF files or images,
then you can certainly include that
at the project level as well.
Okay, great.
So that was projects.
I'll see you in the next one.